Росія посилює обстріли території України
і в Британській і в українській розвідці
застерігають атаки РФ з повітря можуть
ставати масштабнішими з наближенням зими
ціллю знову може стати енергетична
інфраструктура України а також порти
зерносховища та інші цивільні об'єкти
наскільки українська ППО готова закрити
небо що змінилося порівняно з минулою
зимою ДВ зібрала
найголовнішек чова зброя протиповітряної
оборони зенітно-ракетні комплекси раніше
на озброєнні України стояли виключно
радянські зразки зокрема букм1 S300 з
осені Минулого року з'явилися західні
першими установками на самс потім
німецьким айріс який показав надзвичайно
гарні результати ця система з
надзвичайно потужним сучасним радаром
який бачить геть усе в небі І який дає
ціле вказання і на інші комплекси не
лише на пускові установки айрс на
командні пункти та пускові інших
зенітних ракетних систем також станом на
жовтень в Україні Розгорнуті два
американські комплекси patріotт і один
французький самт вони ефективні і проти
ракет і проти Дронів Утім їх мало Ми
сьогодні в в ситуації коли ми змушені
захищати саме локально великі міста
мільйонники де є саме об'єкти критичної
інфраструктури об'єкти атом енергетики
це все потрібно робити От локально так
там об'єкт захистили там там от по
Україні Отак от кружечками Як то кажуть
простими словами поміж тих кружечків де
вже не є захищена територія ворог планує
свої удари до яких російських атак
готуватися Україні у вересні РФ
застосувала рекордну кількість шахедів
503 Дрони на місяць до середини жовтня
запустили ще понад 200 РФ б'є по
цивільному населенню і буде бити по
цивільному населенню здебільшого по
цивільній навіть нецивільній
інфраструктурі просто про населення і і
мова йде про першу загрозу - Це звісно
шахеди як наймасовішу не найбільшу а
просто наймасовішу загрозу шахеди
відносно дешева зброя ці БПЛА зазвичай
атакують групами або роями їхня мета
виснажувати ППО у такому разі
застосування того ж pтріот крайній засіб
- пояснює Юрій Ігнат вартість шахеда Ну
нехай там Десятки тисяч доларів вартість
одної зенітної ровини ракети це вже
сотні тисяч доларів якщо ми берем на
самс То це до півмільйона тому більш
раціонально знищувати шахеда саме от
зенітними рмадами тою зброєю Яка
найбільш ефективна з такого озброєння
ЗСУ має в арсеналі німецькі Зенітні
самохідні установки гепард вони вже
зарекомендували себе як ефективні
винищувачі шахедів радіус ураження
гепарда 4,5 км Ось таким чином гепард
Може на тій відстані запелінгувати його
своїм радаром так тобто
і вже штучний інтелект визначає як
повернути башту в який момент висипати з
тих двох
стволів чергу снарядів високошвидкісних
розривних так зенітних боєприпасів які
100% його знищуть через невеликий радіус
дії гепарди називають малим ППО його
можна застосувати як зброю останньої
Надії щоб закрити ним конкретні об'єкти
Утім кількість гепардів в Україні також
обмежена у Німеччині вони зняті з
виробництва питання зі снарядами для цих
установок частково вирішене Враховуючи
те що 35міліметровий боєприпас Який
використовуються в гепардах це для
системи lкон доволі популярні Річі
насправді у
світі тому Багато хто ну поставив
питання А що буде якщо в нас буде війна
і відповідав rй Metal Він розпочав
виробництво цих боєприпасів у Німеччині
е ну банально через те що він розуміє
попит альтернативою гепардам можуть
слугувати й низка західних систем
Наприклад одна з найбільш досконалих
систем ППО малого радіо суудді Є skynкс
виробництва того ж rймеal у жовтні
Великобританія оголосила про передачу
Україні комплексів ППО ближньої дії
терахок Паладін це також надсучасне
озброєння в Україні комплекс
застосовуватиметься вперше як і
німецький гепард британський Паладін
оглядач Олег катков називає ефективною
шахедобійкою буквально два роки тому був
лише продемонстрований дослідний зразок
Тобто це не те що передають зі складів
чи зі строю певних збройних сил система
яка замовляється аналогічна ситуація
відносно постачання бойових модулів
slinger від австралійської eос будь-яка
країна яка яка знаходиться у стані війни
не може собі дозволити таку розкіш
Мирного часу як одноманітність там де
бракує техніки її замінюють люди аби
збивати російські дрони Україна
застосовує мобільні вогневі групи їх
називають мисливцями за шахедами в уряді
повідомляли що напередодні зими
нарощується кількість таких груп Юрій
Ігнат називає це вимушеним кроком це
люди на пікапах люди на вантажівках
озброєні Зеніт установками ще
радянського зразка зу32 23 зу-232
вірніше так само озброєні кулеметами
крупнокаліберними такими як ДШК утьс та
інші це то Що ефективно це оптичні
приціли Це тепловізійне обладнання
тепловізери це прожектори це лазерні
Системи які допомагають ну власне
прицілюватись і влучно відпрацьовувати
якщо до протистояння з безпілотниками
украї військові дещо призвичаїлися то
однією з найбільших небезпек залишаються
російські керовані ракети с-300 і с400
балістичні ракети Іскандер та
аеробалістичні кинджали Росія нарощує
їхнє виробництво щоб збивати такі ракети
Україні потрібно більше західних систем
ППО балістика є балістика зрозуміло що
немає в нас засобів достатньо щоб
протистояти у нас їх практично взагалі
немає Якщо говорити про два підрозділи
два дивізіони чи дві батареї як кажуть
на заході patріotт Ну то цього замало
щоби перекривати от власне такі великі
територію за словами Олега Каткова щоб
повністю закрити небо принаймні над
великими містами у кожному необхідно
поставити принаймні дві системи на
кшталт pтріот Але є й інший вихід
ситуація могла бути інакшою якби захід
зняв би свою нелюдяну умову не
використовувати його озброєння по
території Росі Російської Федерації тому
що без ураження
пускових без ураження
аеродромів в тому числі Навіть якщо ми
говоримо про тактичну авіацію тобто у
куртки там брянських областях ее
невілювати цю загрозу вкрай складно у
повітряних силах наголошують Україна
розпочала перехід до ППО виключно
західного зразка адже хоча снаряди для
таких систем дорогі і дефіцитні ракети
для радянської техніки теж вичерпуються
і в Україні і за кордоном винищувачі
f-16 доповнять вже доступні Україні
системи irist Patriot на samмs і самt за
словами речника повітряних сил Юрія
ігната українські пілоти які тренуються
для польотів на f-16 за кілька тижнів
почнуть літати на навчальних бойових
літаках за оптимістичними прогнозами f16
з'являться в Україні в першій половині
року okay